[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Evette
[Music]
play me and read I pay you in silver lo
care but in Oh have you met saya lives
on the outskirts of Cetus see he is the
three of us me uncle and headstrong saya
we were inseparable oats
the two of them even got married they
were happy until he disappeared that was
five years ago Sian ever moved on never
accepted it and now I'm hearing queel
whispers the Grenier found some trace of
uncle and just like old times
sai is about to do something rash talk
to her hey for cancer IO we have not
spoken in a long time see you again No
offworlder I'm hiring combat calendar
let's talk late
chut no time to talk
there's worth of my husband I have to go
word travels fast
cons ooh and I haven't spoken in five
years not since his involvement in my
husband's disappearance and now he sends
you by the own I'll accept help if you
bring uncle back to me but miss a trick
and I'll take care of business myself
understood Doka
the doctor no I'll signal you when out
on the plains as crazy as this sounds
you're looking for glass
[Music]
all right ten Oh be careful out here
grineer numbers increase the further you
venture from Cetus patching the austin's
to your signal now my own poll I know
no one cared more for seaters for our
people than heating he worked with the
quills the owners closest servants to
decipher the secrets of the sentient and
the glass warrior who sacrificed herself
to destroy it if you search the camp I
know we'll find some sign of uncle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh-oh this is it this is the degree near
found some of all cause but has he been
hiding
or tail maggots and the greasy evils of
aegis bloody together my soldiers will
guard you all the same I should have
known you'd be behind the Grenier
incursions here who else would be
outmatched troops and a final on David
might further
and I need it for a chance to wrap my
metal bars around your sweet putrid net
scanning the area I'm getting strange
readings from the cave at my Waypoint
smash that drill and go inside ah I
remember that cave on corn I used to
shelter there once I've shielded off
years ago I I hope he's not uncle uncle
he should be here by the Olin is dead
dead cover his it bears uncle's mark he
must be important if it's here and he is
not oh please uncle
no saya kinome I don't say a team
talking ten oh I'm guessing he didn't
tell you he was with my uncle today he
disappeared
this cover is strange I don't understand
the locking mechanism Ted Oh or charge
here orbiters so we can get it open
[Applause]
another job well executed